[Musique]
moi aussi signalé la présence d'un dépôt
sauvage dans un champ à proximité de la
commune on va aujourd'hui s'y rendre
pour essayer de retrouver des preuves et
le propriétaire du dépôt on y va
[Musique]
donc voici le dépôt malheureusement il y
a des gens qui se permettent de jeter
leurs déchets dans la nature donc je
vais essayer de retrouver des preuves
pour essayer d'identifier l'auteur du
fait c'est énormément des déchets de
chantier des gravats voilà ou des
déchets verts il faut savoir que les
déchets verts c'est pas forcément bon
aussi pour l'environnement on pourrait
se dire que c'est biodégradable mais ça
fait pas très propre comme vous le voyez
ici et puis ça apporte aussi des espèces
différentes de celles présentes en forêt
qui peuvent nuire à l'écosystème
[Musique]
on travaille avec aussi énormément de
partenaires ça peut être la gendarmerie
l'eau est né le FB les ecogars mais
aussi tous les administrés puis les
agriculteurs sur le territoire
puisqu'ils énormément de parcelles à
proximité des forêts ou à proximité des
soins communaux donc on est là vraiment
pour apporter notre soutien aux
administrer aux agriculteurs et on n'est
pas là pour le but n'est pas de la
répression mais vraiment la
sensibilisation donc
[Musique]
maintenant on va se rendre sur les temps
de LED pour surveiller les abords de la
rivière et de l'étang pour voir s'il y a
pas des déchets des dépôts voilà ou des
pêcheurs qui n'auraient pas forcément le
permis de pêche